Hallo, hallo, hallo, gehst du los?
Wie los?
Wie wollen wir jetzt erklären, dass wir kein Intro haben?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, dann habe dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum,hausen und Florian Vinnorek. Ui, herzlich willkommen. Alter, was ist gerade los? Wo hört ihr uns gerade? Unglaublich. Ihr müsst das mal ein bisschen aufräumen, kurz gedanklich. Also, die Playlist David Bowie, Lou Reed, Mick Jagger und dann Stefan Tisslinghauer. Was ist denn da eigentlich los? Was ist passiert? Wir haben einige Möhrungen für euch. Wir sind ganz stolz, dass sie präsentieren. Wir laufen ab sofort auch auf Spotify! Nein, dürfen wir leider nicht sagen, aber wen ich richtig gern mag, ist der schwedische Kronkorkenhersteller Schmottify. Die machen richtig gute Arbeit und mit denen werden wir auch zusammenarbeiten. Dürfen wir nicht sagen. Doch, dürfen wir sagen. Wir dürfen nicht sagen, dass wir es nicht sagen dürfen, wir dürfen es aber sagen. Das ist, ich ... Das Problem ist ... Massive rechtliche Schwierigkeiten. Das Problem ist, die gesamten Verträge mit Spotify sind in Schwedisch oder in jeder anderen ... Ich weiss nicht. Leider ist es ... Oder in Spä-risch. Schwierisch. Ich weiss nicht, ich bin nicht sicher. Leider ... Also es ist auf jeden Fall ... Scheiße, das kommt noch nicht raus. Schon jetzt einfach direkt die Handschellen angelegt, klickt, klickt. Vor allem, wir hätten nur die ersten Viertelstunde überleben müssen, weil dann hören die eh nicht mehr rein. Das stimmt. Okay, da ist alles cool, alles rechtlich gelaufen, alles klar. Aber dann hätten wir anfangen können, das zu sagen. Das wir uns in der ersten Minute machen, war nicht unbedingt selber. Das wird wahrscheinlich Konsequenzen, vielleicht bekommen wir jetzt kein Geld mehr, oder wir bekommen sowieso kein Geld. So, ich hätte gerade Babykarotten. Ja, Und du hast letztens gemerkt, dass Babykarotten eigentlich nur klein gefräste, normale Karotten sind. Ja, das wollte ich nur kurz sagen, um da von diesem brenzligen Thema wegzukommen, was so eine Art Minenfeld ist. Will sich denn eigentlich sonst irgendwas ändern beim das Podcast UFO Podcast? Also es gibt immer noch freche Anekdoten, frische Gags und heisse Produktionen in die Zukunft, natürlich auch ein paar Anekdoten aus dem irren Privatleben von Stefan Titzler, aber ansonsten bleibt alles beim selben. Ihr könnt trotzdem noch T-Shirts kaufen, ihr könnt trotzdem noch unsere Becher kaufen, unsere Teddybären kaufen, könnt ihr alles noch machen. Aber ganz kurz mal eben, Leute, also wir glauben, also ich glaube, ihr Fans werdet uns da auch unterstützen auf unserem weiteren Weg, wo wir jetzt auch ein Ausspielmedium mehr haben. Aber wir werden eine neue Titelmusik bekommen. Das ist klar. Das ist euch klar, das ist uns klar. Aber wir wollen euch folgen, wir wollen euch bitten. Ich weiss, diese ganze Nerdkultur, die zerfetzt gerne. Die mögen oft Dinge nicht, an die sie sich erst gewöhnen müssen. Aber bitte heisst die neue Melodie willkommen. Als ein Teil der grossen Podcast-UFO-Familie willkommen. Macht die Türen auf für die neue Melodie, lasst sie erst mal reinkommen, lasst sie erst mal sich vorstellen, sich entfalten und dann könnt ihr entscheiden. Aber gebt erst mal eine Chance. Ich weiß, es ist reizvoll, man will immer sagen, früher war alles besser, um zu zeigen, dass man früher schon Hörer war, aber zeichnet euch doch lieber durch Treue aus und dafür, dass ihr coole Meinungen habt, dadurch zeichnet ihr euch mehr als Podcast-Ufo-Hörer aus, als immer diesen Nostalgie-Scheiss mit euch rumzuschleppen. Oder diesen Spreadshirt-Scheiss mit euch rumzuschleppen. Ja, immer diese Scheisse mit euch rumzutragen. Das war jetzt aber noch nicht das heutige Intro. Nur dass es klar ist. Das war unser neues Intro. Das war jetzt noch die A Cappella-Version. Vielen Dank nochmal an Beyoncé und Kid Rock, die eben da waren und das gesungen haben. Vielen Dank, habt ihr richtig gut gemacht. Ihr könnt jetzt übrigens auch gehen. Könnt gehen, ich weiß nicht, warum ihr noch so rumsteht, so erwartungsvoll, mit euren grossen Katzenaugen. Katzenaugen, Geldaugen, wir haben sie für eine Stunde gebucht, aber eigentlich, you could Gleich lief,, please go. This is Cologne. Cologne is a nice, wonderful city. This is Cologne talking by Beyonce. Ja, auf jeden Fall. See ya. Aber natürlich jetzt ein bisschen Sellout, ne? Gar nicht. Oder vielleicht auch doch. Wir dürfen darüber nichts sagen. Sellout im Sinne von, was meinst du jetzt? Naja, Sell im Sinne, dass wir uns jetzt ja der Masse anbiedern, dass wir jetzt zu Themen machen.
So, ey, hast du schon diese neue Werbung für Kinder-Pinguin gesehen?
Nein!
Wecke den Pinguin in dir. Das ist ja mega lustig, weil das ist ja...
Schaut's nach, gibt's wirklich.
Ja, das ist ja früher wie bei Kellogs Frost ist Wecke den Tiger in dir.
Da haben die bestimmt einfach nur die Idee geklaut, haben aber nicht gemerkt, dass ein Tiger ein wesentlich interessanteres Tier ist als ein Pinguin.
Wecke den Pinguin in dir, was soll das denn heissen, dass man da bis nur noch Fracks trägt und nicht mehr fliegen kann? Ha ha ha ha! So war es halt. Niemand kommt zu Smarties und sagt dann, weckt Smarties in euch und dann weiss niemand mehr, was wo oben und unten ist. Wecke die Toblerone in dir. Äh, okay, alles klar, ich versuch's ganz kurz mal. Ich weck kurz mal die Toblerone in mir. Achtung. Hey Toblerone, wach doch mal, wach doch mal kurz auf bitte. Du musst jetzt nur mit zuziehen, das ist ein lustiges, lustiges Spiel. Ah, guten Morgen! Ja. Oh, wie Toblerone halt zu sprechen, wir wissen's ja halt nicht. Ja. Wir haben sehr viel erlebt. Wir haben, äh, sagen, also Olympia war, können wir leider nicht mehr darüber sprechen, weil es ist jetzt vorbei. Wir haben zwischenzeitlich eine Folge aufgenommen, wo wir sehr viel über Olympia gesprochen haben, die wir alle löschen mussten, die müssen die komplette Folge löschen. Leute, die bei Patreon mehr als 50 Euro spenden, kriegen die vielleicht nochmal irgendwann als Giveaway. Guter Punkt. Wir haben ja noch ein paar Giftschrankfolgen, die wir zwar noch haben, aber nie veröffentlicht haben. Aber sorry, wir haben uns einfach ganz kurz zusammengesetzt. Es war auch kein guter Tag, weil ich weiß nicht, deine Schwester ist vorher kurz gestorben und so. Naja, lassen wir jetzt mal kurz weg diese ganze Sache. Und ja, dann haben wir über Olympia ganz viel gesprochen, viele Gags gemacht. Dann waren wir beide bei Bill Burr in Köln und bei Louis C. K. in Amsterdam. Ja. Und wir als Comedy-Nerds sollten euch da natürlich was anderes von erzählen, wie es war. Eine kleine Konzertkritik. Oder ich weiss nicht, wie man sagt. Wie hast du Olympia erlebt? War es für dich ein heisser Ritt? Ich würde sagen, es war ein Ritt auf der Fechtklinge. Ja. Wie ein Sprung von einem Sieben-Meter-Turm. Ja. Ich fand es Wahnsinn. Ich finde Olympia jedes Jahr aufs neue Wahnsinn. Und mir fällt immer wieder auf, wie viel Spaß das macht zu gucken einfach. Weil das ist eine der wenigen Veranstaltungen, wo du komplett abschalten kannst. Du kannst dich da vorsetzen und du hast unfassbar neue, also für mich als jemand, der unfassbar viele neue Eindrücke immer braucht und sich kaum auf fünf Minuten auf etwas konzentrieren kann, für mich ADHS-Junkie ist das perfekt, weil du hast Reiten und die springen durch seltsame Hindernisse, die aussehen wie kleine Miniatur-Wunderländer, dann cut it, wir springen in ein grünes Becken, niemand, Forscher wissen nicht, warum es grün ist, Cut, wir machen Fechten, aber das ist nur Fünfkampf, das heißt, danach müssen die schwimmen. Cut, die kommen gerade aus dem Wasser und jetzt laufen tausende Menschen vom Wasser an Land. Cut, einer hat eine brennende Fackel in der Hand. What the fuck, warum, okay. Das ist so cool, weil du springst von einer Welt in eine ganz andere und dann sind aber immer kämpfen die gleichen Länder um Medaillen. Das ist toll. Ich finde es einerseits so toll, weil es ist ein Olympia, so weisst du, die besten Athleten der ganzen Welt kommen zusammen und du hast ja dieses griechische vor dir, so diese körperliche Exzellenz, diese mentale Stärke, diese unglaubliche Disziplin, die werden alle gedrillt, von ihrer Kindheit aufgeputscht, jeden Tag gibt alles, aber dann auf der anderen Seite wirkt das alles so Hobbymässig irgendwie, so albern, weil die können ja davon nicht leben. Die werden halt gedrillt, aber halt leider einfach nur im Bogenschießen. Ja, aber halt nur von 16 bis 19 Uhr jeden Donnerstag halt mal. Und dann kommen die halt da an und dann denkst du dir, okay, das sind die krassesten Athleten der Welt, aber dann so Reitwettbewerb und die springen dann halt über so kleine Miniaturhäuser, wo du denkst, okay, dafür hast du dein ganzes Leben gearbeitet. Das ist eine komplette Abwesenheit von Coolness. Es gab ein Hindernis, das war eine Hecke, eine ganz grosse, so ein Wald mit einem Loch drin. Da war so ein bisschen Nebel auch, da war glaube ich Nebel in der Maschine und so. Und dann springst du da durch wie in so einem Wunderwald. Und dann ist alles so, sind wir jetzt noch so ein Film oder ist es Werbung für einen Film? Und so aus Ton gefertigte kleine Feen und so mit Zauberstäben. Was ist das hier? Das ist eine olympische Disziplin.
Und da habe ich auch mal gehört, dass ehemalige Olympioniken designen ja die Strecken.
Ach was.
Und dann ist mir auch aufgefallen.
Aber von denen haben ja eigentlich die meisten verloren.
Genau, das heißt, die wollen extra noch Arschlöcher.
Von 100 Olympioniken haben 99 verloren.
Und dann müssen wir in Looping fahren, BMX-Rat.
Und dann machen wir noch eine Eiswelt und eine Wüstenwelt, ihr fucking Idioten. Und niemand wird die Scheissstrecke überleben, ihr motherfucking Arschlöcher. Das ist ganz schön hart. Aber dann ist mir aufgefallen, was ich auch gut finde, dass die Leute Weltrekorde brechen. Das ist einfach was Cooles, weil ich finde es cool, wenn Leute wissen, dass sie von etwas das Beste jemals aller Zeiten waren, im Universum, weil diese Besponder gibt es auf keine andere Welt. ist cool, das ist ein cooles Bewusstsein, du hast was Messbares, was wir in unserem Job gar nicht haben, du hast was Messbares, das ist cool. Und in manchen Strecken, wenn die halt immer neue Streckendesign, so BMX oder so, können die ja keinen Weltrekord brechen, weil es sind immer neue Strecken, die dauern immer halt ein bisschen anders lang. Oder wenn sowas wie Wind reinspielt. Ich sagte aber immer, das Weltrekord hat man halt quasi nur beim Schwimmen und so. Und halt vielleicht beim Schiessen oder so, wo halt die Bedingungen immer gleich sind. Das war mir gar nicht so bewusst. Ja, ja, stimmt schon. Ja, und vor allem auch dann immer, ich finde es so beeindruckend, gerade so dieser 100-Meter-Sprint oder so, dass es so extrem kurz ist. Weißt du, so bei der Fussball-WM, da schaust du über Wochen hin lang immer wieder Spiele und dann verlieren die mal oder kriegen mal ein Tor rein und dann Spannung, aber da ist es der, der trainiert sein ganzes Leben und das vier Jahre lang, trainiert und dann okay, Schuss, neun Sekunden, aus und das war's und dann ist der der Beste und wir können heimgehen. Und die ganzen Leute, die in dieses Stadion kommen, die kommen ja vor allem nur für Usain Bolt, weil das der krasseste Star ist, der Leiterlehrig, kommen da hin, reisen über Tage an, manche fliegen sogar 18 Stunden dahin, komm da an, warten neun Sekunden und gehen. Komm morgens auf dem Parkplatz an, setz dich da hin, es ist sauheiss, wollen guten Platz. Und dann sitzt du wahrscheinlich noch auf der anderen Seite des Stadions. Du musst ja bei so einem Fussballspiel, da ist ja die Action ungefähr gleich verteilt über den ganzen Platz. Das heißt, egal wo du sitzt, du kriegst was mit. Aber bei so einem Olympia-100 Meter, das ist ja gerade mal mal so eine Kurve von so einer Laufbahn. Das heißt, wenn du auf der anderen Seite sitzt, siehst du da so winzige Leute und dann Schuss irgendwie, die Schallgeschwindigkeit hörst du sowieso erst acht Minuten später, dass das Rennen überhaupt erst angefangen hat. Dann laufen die da, ach fuck, vor acht Minuten war das Rennen und dann, wer hat gewonnen, kurz auf Twitter gucken. Noch bevor du den Schuss hörst, kannst du auf Twitter lesen, wer gewonnen hat, dann denkst du ja, gut Leute. Und dann fallen leider im richtigen Moment richtigen Moment, wenn du richtig sitzt, auch noch die Tacos runter in dem Moment. Ja genau. Und dann steht jemand vor dir auf und dann geht er zu auf Toilette und so. Das ist glaube ich ein richtig gescheites Erlebnis. Das ist echt einfach. Aber da haben auch so viele Beschwerde darüber, dass die Ränge immer leer waren bei Olympia. Aber ist das nicht komplett verständlich? Weil ich meine, je besser das Fernsehen wird, desto weniger hat man noch, auch wenn ich da leben würde, würde ich noch nicht ins Stadion gehen. Ja, vor allem gerade bei Olympia ist ja auch die technische Übertragung hilft ja auch wahnsinnig viel, also zum Beispiel so, keine Ahnung, so Schiessen, also die Schiessen auf ein Ziel. Wenn du das aus 200 Metern, du siehst die Zielscheibe nicht, der Athlet bewegt sich nicht, er bewegt nur seinen Finger, du hast überhaupt keine Action und du siehst nicht mal die Zielscheibe.
Wo du gerne auf dem Fernseher hast, du ein Close-up und du siehst Splitscreen, wie der hat sich konzentriert und so. Du hast auch so eine Animation und so einen Scheiss. Genau, weisst du genau wie viel und Stadion gar nicht. Da hast du jemandem, der die Regeln erklärt. Das ist ja auch bei solchen Dingen, also du hast so viele, so ein grosses Schiessstadion, wie das da war, so viele Schiessfans sieht es doch überhaupt gar nicht. Ja, und dann vor allem dann ist es auch noch so wahnsinnig viel Disziplin, da gibt es eine Pistole, ein Maschinengewehr, zwei Pistolen, dann einmal 360 Grad Drehung und dann schiessen, einmal mit dem Gewehr, einmal mit dem und dann hat jeder noch mal eine andere Goldmedaille. Und dann gab es einer, genau einer hat sogar eine Goldmedaille gewonnen, der hat im Schnellschießen, Schnellfeuerwaffe. Das heißt, das war ein total geiler Wettbewerb, habe ich gesehen, haben auch Gold bekommen, wir vor allem. Jetzt hat man da irgendwas mitgemacht, Andreas Fink oder so hieß der. Und dann musste er einfach, er hat vier Sekunden Zeit, die Waffe zu heben und fünf verschiedene, so ungefähr zehn Zentimeter Durchmesserpunkte zu treffen. Aber halt in vier Sekunden muss er die anheben, fünf Ziele treffen und dann wieder senken die Waffe. Und da hat er auch Goldring gewonnen. Und das war halt so ein, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen untersetzter Typ, halt so mit so einer Kappe rauf. Klassischer Amokläufer. Ich dachte die ganze Zeit, das sind klassische Amokläufer. Und bei jedem, der kam, dann kam er danach, der Russe, danach der Amerikaner, ich dachte mir so, nein, nein, nein, nein. Und warum müssen wir Deutschen in jedem Schiesswettbewerb die Goldmedaille bekommen? Das ist der einzige Wettbewerb, wo ich das nicht will. Aber die sind alle aus wie Amokläufer, die haben alle Kehlen. Das sind vor allem auch immer so ganz abgefahrene Spacewaffen, irgendwie, die dann so ganz unförmig und klobig irgendwie sind, die dann auch so Gegengewichte dran haben und die so mega high-tech. Das sind auch immer total abgefahren. Ach, dieser Bogen. Ja, der Bogen ist auch krass, mit Gegengewichten und so, wo ich mir denke, ist es da noch so schwer da zu treffen? Also natürlich ist es schon schwer, aber auf der einen Seite denke ich mir, na ja, vor allem dann hört man immer, ja die macht das jetzt seit zwei Jahren so, seit zwei Jahren. Wow, die macht seit zwei Wochen. Je weniger Leute Zeit haben zu proben, desto weniger akzeptiert man den Sport auch als Sport. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt auch diese coole Frau, die Amerikanerin, die irgendwie jedes Jahr Tonschaum schiessen gewinnt, die krasseste Athletin in diesem Wettbewerb ist, ist aber eine fette Frau, so eine fette Mom, die jeden Tag PBJ-Brötchen schmiert für ihre Kinder und dann halt da steht und nicht mal richtig zielt. Die hat das einfach durchgespielt, die hat im Alter von zwölf, weil die sagt, okay, ich bin einfach die Beste da drin und macht es seitdem immer weiter und die stemmt halt so in ihre Hüfte, so auch nicht mal so richtig professionell, da ist auch keine richtige Haltung, da steckt kein Sportwissenschaft dahinter, stemmt einfach so rein, schiesst und trifft halt, da ist immer ein Genie da drin, der hat einfach gewonnen. Und so nebenbei hat noch ein Kind irgendwie auf eurem Bauch irgendwie geschnürt, einfach so neben bam bam bam bam bam bam. Stellt dabei ihr Kind und killt alle Tontaugen. Ja genau, ruft noch irgendwie den Rektor an, dass der Sohn irgendwie nicht nachsissen muss oder so nebenbei. Und ein Faschbeil, so eine Mom, so eine fette Mom. Das ist geil, Olympia ist toll. Und vor allem auch diese seltsamen Kombinationen dann aus dem, wo du denkst, okay, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel eine Sportart, die ist orientiert an Kavallerieoffizieren aus dem 18. Jahrhundert oder sowas. Die müssen dann irgendwie rennen, reiten, mit Pistole schiessen, fechten. Und Pringles essen, sehr viel Pringles essen. Pringles essen, einfach Salto und dann noch irgendwie einen Scheuner aufräumen oder sowas. Also genau, ganz extrem präzise, wo dann diese acht Sportarten, Oktalon oder Pogtalon oder was auch immer, die das dann machen müssen. Also auch ganz seltsam, dass du denkst, hm, ich habe diese fünf Fähigkeiten, das passt genau darauf. So, das ist dann so, ja gut, aber ich kann jetzt noch Hammer werfen, leider nicht dabei, sorry. Das ist so seltsam. Das ist echt ganz merkwürdig. Vor allem, also dass du weisst, dass du in einer Sportart, die wenig Fans hat, der dreissig Beste der Welt bist. Ist das nicht mega uncool? Von fünfzig. Ich meine, wir sind auch. Wir sind wahrscheinlich so die unter den Top, weiss ich nicht, acht hunderttausend Comedy-Autoren der Welt, oder? Weiss ich nicht. Die ausüben, nicht die sein wollen oder besser wären im Prinzip, weiss ich nicht. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen, keine Ahnung, kein Maßstab. In Deutschland, sagen wir 800.000 in Deutschland. Wir wissen halt nichts, aber das ist echt krass, weil wir haben keinen Maßstab. Ich glaube, es wäre auch extrem demütigend, wenn wir wüssten, dass wir nicht mal unter die besten zehn Millionen der Welt kommen oder so. Das wäre so extrem traurig. Wir sind nicht mal gut in dem, was wir seit Jahren machen. Ich glaube, ich habe einen besseren Platz irgendwie beim Springreiten als bei dem, was ich beruflich mache. Kann gut sein. Ich glaube, ich bin der zehnmillionste Comedyautor, aber der vierhundertste Springreitentyp oder so was in meiner Gewichtsklasse. Das kann sein. Das ist ganz strange auch. Wie entscheidet man sich, dass man jetzt Weitsprung macht und nicht alles andere, was man daneben, also springt sie dann nur weit in ihrem Leben, ist das so ihr Ding? Ja, aber nicht hoch. Ich kann sehr weit springen, aber nicht hoch. Aber nicht hoch, ich bin sehr schlecht darin, aber sehr gut darin. Was muss da passieren, wie viele Entscheidungen müssen getroffen werden, bis man das macht? Aber da habe ich auch so eine Reportage gesehen, wo die sich dieses Problems ja bewusst sehen, dass das kein Schwanz interessiert. Die sind ja nicht bescheuert, Florentin. Und dann haben die immer so Segmente gemacht, wo sie versucht haben zu erklären, warum dieses Sport jetzt interessant ist. Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel auch dieses, ich weiss nicht, wie das heisst, aber wo Pferde einfach eine Choreografie machen. Dressur. Die nicht über irgendwas drüber springen, sondern die tanzen einfach. Das ist Wahnsinn, habe ich auch gesehen, das ist Wahnsinn. Vor allem, ganz kurz, Exkurs, die machen, also die können sich die Musik auswählen.
Und natürlich ist das so eine sehr anmutende Sportart. In der Hälfte von Gema, ja. Das ist so eine sehr anmutende Sportart, immer mit, dann hopsen die und dann reiten die sanft über den Boden, dann müssen die Füsse immer einen gewissen Abstand haben, einen Winkel. Und dann haben natürlich die meisten, hören natürlich Klassik, da läuft ein Klassik-Track im Hintergrund und die Pferde orientieren sich auch ein bisschen da dran. Und dann hat irgendwie eine Deutsche, die dann auch irgendwie Gold oder so gewonnen hat, die lächerlich gut darin war, die lief einfach so ein Trance-Tracking im Hintergrund, so ein Schlager, so ein Ballermann hielt einfach so als so ein uncooler Text dabei und so. Es passt überhaupt nicht zur Sportart, aber das Pferd hat die ganze Zeit mitgemacht, hat so übertrieben auch im Takt mitgemacht, wo ich mir auch dachte, als Juror würde ich dann für die Musik abzugeben. Aber das können die halt nicht ausbinden. Vor allem bei diesen Reitplätzen, die haben auch immer so scheiss Boxen. Die haben dann irgendwie so uralte Medion-Boxen, irgendwie am anderen Ende des Reitplatzes, wo das dann so raus plärrt. Und die wohnen in so, also die Juroren sind in so Pavillons. Warum sitzen die ja nicht einfach am Rand? Nein, die haben so weisse Pavillons, wo so Blumensträuße da vorgelegt sind, so als ob irgendein Schwein interessiert, dass es dekoriert ist. Und die Fechter, das ist einfach nur alles so mega funktional. Alle haben so, das ist nicht schön. Aber bei denen ist alles so, das ist total strange. Ja, aber ich war mal in München auf einer Pferdeschau und du denkst dir einfach, da können es die geilsten Pferde der Welt und die fähigsten Reiter der Welt sein.
Es kommt keine coole Stimmung auf, weil die Musik scheisse ist und die Qualität so schlecht ist. Es kommt einfach nicht auf. Aber da habe ich auch in dieser Reportage hieß es dann auch, ja, Fechten mögen die Leute nicht. Es gibt ja auch wieder drei verschiedene Fechtarten. Es gibt ja drei verschiedene... Degenfechten, Fechten, Fechten, Fechten. Also diese drei verschiedene Schwerter oder drei verschiedene Waffen, die dann irgendwie nochmal einen anderen Kampfstil haben, weil die dann schwerer sind oder andere Trefferzonen zählen, was auch immer. Und dann hieß es auch so von wegen, ja, die haben sich so überlegt, weil keine Sau das interessiert, dass sie coolere Helme machen. Und dann haben sie dann so einen Helm gezeigt, der so aussieht wie so eine Darth-Punk-Helm, der so eine Art Schutzwiesel hier rumrum hat, war so völlig unnötig, aber du kannst auch einen Darth-Wader-Helm tragen, wenn du willst. Wir haben jetzt zwei Hörner, ich weiß nicht, musst du nicht nicht nehmen. Ja genau, das ist ganz merkwürdig. Aber ich finde, wo so am meisten dieser Hobby-Charakter von Olympia klar wurde, war ein Moment, wo so ein Weltklasse-Golfer, Golfer er zum ersten Mal jetzt ja immer wieder, Abschlag gemacht hat, aber er ist dann ein bisschen über die Absperrung hinaus, wo er schon Publikum sah. Und dann saß da einfach so ein alter Mann, er hat dann telefoniert, hat sich überhaupt gar nicht interessiert, was er geglaubt ist, sieht er, dass der Ball auf ihn rollt, nimmt ihn einfach in die Hand, rückt ihn so an, telefoniert einfach weiter und Leute, alle, da laufen so hundert Leute auf ihn rum, die gestikulieren so, nein, das dürfen sie nicht anfassen. Aber das Publikum gilt ja als Teil der Hindernisse am Kurs.
Genau genommen gilt die ganze Welt darum als Hindernis am Kurs.
Und wenn die dann das treffen, dann müssen die halt, theoretisch muss der Typ dann sitzen bleiben, dann müssen die dahinter halt versuchen, den Ball zu treffen. Er darf auch nicht weggehen. Nein. Können Sie bitte weggehen? Nein, ich bin Teil des Hindernisses. Oder irgendwer hat dann den Ball genommen und ist dann im gleichen Radius zum Loch so weit gegangen, bis das Publikum nicht mehr da war. Das heißt, du darfst dann halt im gleichen Abstand um das Loch herum, aber der Typ hat einfach den Ball genommen.
Ja, was passiert, wenn du den Ball nimmst und einfach wirfst in den engsten See? Ja, dann wird halt so ein Videobeweis genommen und dann wird dann da, wo der Typ den genommen hat, ein Arschloch hintermiss. Fuck you, Harald, bei jedem fucking Turnier bist du und wirfst den Ball wieder weg. Am besten war dann auch die Geste von der Frau, die er nicht gehört hat.
Ey, hat die Arme so hochrissen. Was zum Teufel? Sie konnte auch nichts dagegen machen, die ist nicht mehr eingegriffen. Da geht es um richtig Geld und die hat nicht mehr eingegriffen. Um Freigetränke, um ein paar Gutscheiben. Da geht es um Pommes Mayo. Ähnliches hatten wir bei dem Baseballspiel, das wir in New York gesehen haben, auch, wo dann der Ball ins Publikum flogen ist und es hätte einen Unterschied gemacht, ob er nur gegen die Fassade geprallt wäre und dann wieder zurück aufs Feld oder ob in der Zeit schon jemand ihn berührt hätte. Und da war dann so ein kleines Mädchen, das so halb ins Gesicht bekommen hat und nur weil die ihn berührt hatte, waren dann irgendwie die Regeln anders. Alle hassen dieses süsses Mädchen. Ja, dieses scheiss Mädchen, weil deswegen die Mets irgendwie die Millionen Dollar verloren haben. Aber stell dir mal vor, dass eine Sportart wirklich, also dass so ein kleines Mädchen die Mets in den Ruin treiben könnte, weil die einfach in der Liga absteigen, weil so ein Skandalwurf oder so. Ja klar, die müssen die ganzen guten Spieler verkaufen, spielen die nächste Saison noch schlechter und sinken immer weiter ab. Das ist ein Todes, das ist ein Teufelskreis. Du weisst ja, was mit den Red Sox passiert ist. Ich meine, das war eine Geschichte. Das war echt ein Drama. Das war echt nichts. Wahnsinn, Olympia ist wirklich toll.
Ja.
Aber leider nur alle vier Jahre.
Wobei, ich habe aber ein bisschen genug jetzt davon.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall genug.
Aber ich meine, Winterolimpiade, hallo?
Ja, ein Riesenskeleton.
Ich meine, ich bin ein Riesenskeleton-Fan.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Skeleton.
Ich bin wirklich ein grosser Fan vom Namen Skeleton.
Ich weiss gar nicht, was das ist. Skeleton. Skifahren meinst du? Nein, Skeleton meine ich. Skelett. Skeleton. Skelet. Skeleton ist eine Sportart. Da muss man mit so einem Art Schlitten durch die Bobbahn fahren. Mit so einer Art Schlitten. Es ist nicht Schlitten, es ist eine andere Art des Schlitten. Du liegst, glaube ich, auch drauf, dass diese Flossen an, das ist ganz strange alles. Aber ich habe vielleicht keine Flossen an, sondern die Füsse haben einfach so seltsame, weiss ich nicht, jemals liegen die so da drauf und dann fahren die halt auf so einer Art Schlitten, so eine Art Rollbrett-Schlitten durch die Bahn, die sonst für andere Sportarten wie Bob benutzt wird, ich finde das die Bobbahn. Und was eine seltsame Sportart, die mit den Mitteln lebt, die eine andere Sportart, die den gebracht hat. Tatsächlich der erste Promi, den ich in meinem Leben gesehen habe, war der Georg Hackel, der Hackelschorsch, wie wir ihn genannt haben. Ganz grosse Sensation, sehr stolz, gerade im bayerischen Raum. Und da waren wir in Bayern, Ausflug, irgendwie Königssee oder sowas in der Richtung, und dann stand er da einfach am Ufer, stand da, kontemplativ.
Einfach so am Ufer?
Stand er einfach da.
Promis stehen einfach so manchmal am Ufer?
Promis stand da, der erste Promis.
Hat mich, also Schlittenfahren hat mich überhaupt nicht interessiert, aber, oder Bobrodeln,
glaube ich, sagt man eher, man muss halt auch immer so, das ist nämlich auch immer so,
also die Begriffe sind teilweise schon wichtig, glaube ich.
Nämlich teilweise, die sind extrem.
Ja, also zum Beispiel, unsere Maskendame korrigiert auch immer, ich ... Ihr Name. Ja, die Claudia oder so. Nee, aber dass man irgendwie sagt, nicht Schminke, man darf nicht Schminke sagen, sondern Make-up und man darf auch nicht, man soll Maskenbildnerin sagen und nicht irgendwas anderes, irgendwie ein Abwehrbegriff oder sowas. Aber dann auch gab es ja immer so von der ARD oder von der Sportschau diese Zusammenfassungs-Videos und da hieß dann auch irgendwie, beim Trampolin hat dann jemand gewonnen und dann hieß es dann irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, Clara Falkenstedt hüpft zum Gold. Und so was, und ich dachte, ja, ich verstehe, wo ihr hinwollt, aber die Frau trainiert halt ihr ganzes Leben und das wäre ihr grosser Traum und ihr Titel mit hüpft, weißt du, hüpft. Floratin witzelt zu Gold. Ja, genau. Das ist so, das ist so, du gewinnst Gold dafür, dass du hüpfst, das ist schon echt demütig, weisst du, die arme Frau, die sich das anschaut, aber es rodelt zum Gold, das ist ja auch nicht so, ja gut, aber es klingt so aus Versehen, es klingt so belanglos, alles klingt so ein bisschen professioneller als Schlittenfahren, das machen Kinder im Winter, also Schlittenfahren, dafür habe ich Gold geholt, also das hat schon, auf jeden Fall, ich habe mich damals nicht getraut, den Hacker Schorsch anzusprechen, weil ich hätte auch nicht gewusst, was ich, aber das war der erste Promi. Ich glaube, man erinnert sich immer an seinen ersten, was war dein erster Promi, den du gesehen hast? Ach, gute Frage. Du bist so ein FDP-Politiker, oder? Du warst mal auf so einer FDP-Parteiveranstaltung. Ich glaube, ich habe mal Blue, die Band Blue gesehen, am Flughafen, am Düsseldorfer Flughafen. Blue? Ja, so eine Boyband, so eine Boyband aus England. Also bis die ersten waren, weiß ich nicht. Nicht Blue Man Group. Nein. Nee, aber die haben... Sie sind recht auffällig. Ja, kann sein, dass ich sie schon mal gesehen habe, aber sie sind mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen. So ein blauer Typ, entschuldigen Sie, sind Sie von der Blue Man Group? Nee. Okay, sorry. Passiert mir andauert. Ich werde andauernd für jemanden aus der Blue Man Group gehalten. Ich weiß nicht warum. Weiss nicht warum, ja. Aber Blue, aber nicht am Blue Double Doe, oder? Am Blue Double Die Double Doe Die. Früher war Musik so viel einfacher irgendwie, einfach heute irgendwie Let The Sky Fall und früher am Blue Double Die Double Die. Am Blue Double Die Double Die, la la la, da da da, die die ganz grossen Hits. Ey Macarena, auch Phantasiesprache oder sowas, ja. Come on Shake Your Baller la la la. Was genau? Ich dachte immer oft, dass die eine Knarre meinen. Baller la la la. Nee. Für mich war immer Baller la la la. Come on Shake Your Baller la la. Ich sage immer so eine Kindersprache für eine Ballermaschine. Ach so, ja. Womit ballert man? Mit Kanonen, mit Pistolen.
Komm, man schlägt hier, ballerlalala.
Das ist ein sehr spezifischer Song für das mexikanische Drogenkartell oder sowas.
Die Waffen hier!
Auch so viel zu fröhlich für den Anlass eigentlich.
Das ist schon echt.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, dass ich in dieser Reportage über diese Olympiasportarten
gesehen habe für diese Dressur, Drainage, Drainage, Drainage, in der dann tanzen und dann hieß es, ja, die Kunst ist es, es möglich so aussehen zu lassen, als würde das Pferd die ganze Arbeit machen. Ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, aber auf der anderen Seite macht das Pferd ja auch die ganze Arbeit.
Also ich verstehe schon so von wegen, ja, man muss eine entspannte Körperhaltung haben und man darf jetzt nicht da mit hochrotem Gesicht und jetzt hier und während das Pferd da ganz sanft tanzt. Der Reiter muss möglichst entspannt aussehen und das ist die undankbarste Sportart der Welt. Wenn irgendwann jemand das so aussieht, dass er dabei ein Sudoku macht, um zu suggerieren, dass er gerade ganz woanders ist. Das Pferd macht die ganze Arbeit. Was, ich hab Gold? Ich sitze den Hopps oder auch so die Rolle viel zu weit. Aber es ist wirklich per Definition die undankbarste Sportart, weil du so tun musst, als hättest du keinen Teil am Erfolg. Du gewinnst, wenn du am wenigsten damit zu tun hast. Genau das ist mir mal Formel 1, wo du sagst, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Herr Schuhmacher. Nee, das war also Auto. Glückwünsch dir mein Auto hier, guter Wagen, du. Nee, aber es ist einfach, Das Pferde, das ist überhaupt fehl. Warum dritt deine Impressions immer in Hans-Hamburgerischer ab eigentlich? Das ist immer nur Auto. Du, gute, gute, gute Haube, du. Ich meine, Leute. Gute Haube, du. Aber das sind so Pferde mit Polo, Conan O'Brien hat ja letztens Polo gespielt. Und auch das ist so absurd irgendwie, das so... Also das ist ja schon echt... Aber das ist schon... Nene, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, und du den so vor dir herdribbelst, darfst du ja den anderen Reiter wegdrängen einfach so.
Das ist ja wirklich auch brutal.
Du benutzt mir so viele Fachbegriffe, als ob du nur den Conan und Brian.
Dribbeln.
Ball hast du gesagt, dribbeln, reiten, das sind die ganzen Sachen, wo ich nicht abkaufe, dass ich es zum ersten Mal gesehen habe.
Ja, aber vor allem, ich habe dann tatsächlich, weil dann kommt man in so eine YouTube-Phase, ich weiss nicht, ob du das kennst, du siehst, Conan und Brian spielt Polen und ich meine, hm, ist das eine coole Sportart?
Die Antwort ist relativ schnell, nein.
Und dann so Top Ten Polo-Goals habe ich dann... Top Ten Zac Efron shirtless. Und dann bist du in so einer Schleife drin und plötzlich guckst du dir den Gay-Porn an. Ich meine, das ist schon crazy. Und dann kommt deine Mutter rein, du musst so alles erklären. Ja, ja, und dann Polo, ich interesse mich für Polo. Ich bin Polo-Wars! Ich meinte, man den Polo-Tap schnell wechselt, Zac Efron! Und dann waren es die Top-Ten-Polo-Goals, die aber immer daraus bestanden, dass so ein Typ von der Mittellinie aus den Ball halt geschossen hat ins Tor und die anderen ihr Pferd einfach nicht unter Kontrolle halten, dass sie da schnell genug reagieren konnten. Das waren eigentlich im Grunde die tollen Polo-Tore. Es kann sogar sein, dass ich bei Olympia Momente live gesehen habe, die für den Sport die Welt verändert haben. Absolut, ja. Und du checkst es nicht, weil selbst die geilsten Momente dieser Sportart für dich immer noch so, ja, cool sind. Du bist nicht dabei, also du bist schon dabei, aber du merkst es nicht, wenn Weltgeschichte geschrieben wird. Vor allem ich denke mir bei Polo, warum lässt man nicht die Pferde den Ball spielen? Die sind ja stark und die haben ja Hufen, die können das ja gut machen. Ich finde das so strange. Und dann im nächsten Jahr lässt man einfach die Reiter weg und lässt einfach nur noch die Pferde einfach Polo spielen. Dann hast du nämlich eine reine Tiersportart, die es ja noch nicht gibt. Ich finde es so strange, dass du Pferde benutzt bei einem menschlichen Sportwettkampf ist ein riesen Mittelfinger in Richtung aller anderen Tierarten. Auf jeden Fall. Warum hebst du die so hoch, dass du mit denen was machst, warum hast du kein Hunderennen oder so, wo kleinen Büchse ist auch Rennen. Also gut, da rennen dann nur die Hunde. Ja, aber als Olympiasportler. Hunde können alleine rennen, selbst beim Pferderennen hast du noch Jockeys, aber beim Hunderennen, yes! Hast du noch, uh, aber dann hast du gerade die Kurve bekommen. Ja, selbst beim Hunderennen hast du keine Reiter. Vielen Dank. Aber die rennen ja auch so einem Hasen hinterher, die raffen ja nicht mal, dass sie in einem Rennen sind. Das ist so damnlich, ey. So ein Hund könnte der gefilzter Rennhund der Welt sein und der würde es nicht mal raffen, weil er denkt, ich renne dem Hasen hinterher. Aber ich mag nicht mal Hasen, aber... So oft wie Menschen sagen, der beste Freund des Menschen ist der Hund, weiss ich nicht, ob das so positiv für einen Menschen ist, so einen wahnsinnig dummen besten Freund zu haben. Und vor allem, also blöd für den Hund, ne, also vor allem ist dann der Hund auch der beste, der Mensch auch der beste Freund des Hundes, Er nicht, überhaupt nicht. Nee, der hält ihn gefangen. Der hält ihn gefangen. Allein dieses Prinzip Leine macht er schon sehr viel deutlich.
Was ist das hier für eine Freundschaft? Ist das eine gesunde Beziehung hier gerade? Ich habe irgendeines Gefühl.
Ich glaube nicht. Und die züchten hier vor allem halt einfach kaputt. Ich habe da letztens noch mal so eine Reportage gesehen, dass sie einfach wirklich kaputt gezüchtet werden, dass diese Tiere auch einfach keine fünftige Lebenserwartung haben und auch teilweise deren Gliedmasse so seltsam, also dass sie halt süss aussehen, dass sie halt so seltsam gezüchtet werden, dass sie halt kaum noch lebensfähig sind und auch ihr Herz und die Organe teilweise so unpassend sind, dass sie Atemnöte haben und irgendwie ganz schnell Krankheiten bekommen, weil deren Körper halt einfach nach menschlichem Vorbild so, oh was ist denn süss, lass uns die noch mal niedlich aussehen, oh und die Füsse sind so klein stumm und ich ha, ha, aber dass das Tier halt einfach fucking leidet und einfach sagt, fucking kill me, ich bin nicht lebensfähig. Es kennt es ja nicht anders, es denkt einfach, dass Leben in einem riesen Höllenritt, genau wie diese Möpse, die schon gezüchtet werden, dass sie so atmen. Ja, einfach, dass sie niedlich sind. Und du siehst hier wirklich, dass diesen Besitzer und seinen Hund, hörst du auch von einem Kilometer, das war man neulich in Köln, lief einfach so ein Mops rum, ich dachte mir, wo kommen diese Geräusche, ist das irgendwie ein Auto, ich wollte aus dem Weg gehen. Man war einfach in sehr weiter Entfernung, war halt so ein Hund. Und die behandeln das Menschen? Ja, vor allem die sollen ja niedlich sein, halt so, dass der, der ist so krank und so schwach und ich kümmere mich um ihn. Das heißt, der Mensch richtet absichtlich den Hund zugrunde, nur um dann was zu haben, wo er sein Mitleid geben kann und wo er niedlich sein kann. So ein fucking Urhund, so ein fucking Wolf, da hätte er der Wolf-Mitleid mit dem fucking dummen, fetten, Cheeto-fressenden Menschen,
anstatt dass er den... Das ist, glaube ich, die grosse Rache eigentlich, dass sie einfach eine Rasse dominieren und einfach so kaputt richten,
dass sie mir dann sagen, oh, der sieht ja total lustig aus, wenn der einen Hut auf hat.
Ja, ja, das ist meine grosse These, dass das Lebewesen die Krönung der Evolution ist, dass anderen Leuten, dass anderen Tieren eine GoPro aufsetzt. Einfach beliebig einfach kaputt degeneriert. Vor allem, es hätte jedes andere Tier treffen können. Es hätte ja nicht auch nur den Wolf treffen können, es hätte ohne Wartes einen Fuchs, den Bären, einen Reh, einen Schmetterling hätte genauso getroffen können und sagen können, du bist jetzt unser Tier, das wir einfach zugrunde richten. Ich will nur, Schmetterling würde ich mal ein Fragezeichen da dran machen. Ja, für die Bälle vielleicht. Und einen Rechtschreibfehler, weil Schmetterling gesagt, aber ich würde zumindest mal ein Fragezeichen da machen. Aber ein Bär von mir aus, man hätte genauso gut ein Bär, so ein kleines Bärchen. Ohne Witz, wenn die vor 200 Jahren angefangen hätten, Bären zu domestizieren und zu züchten, hätten wir heute kleine Teddybärchen, die wir halt an der Leine durch die Innenstadt mitschleppen können, aber das haben die nicht gemacht, die haben sich für den Wolf entschieden und dann Hund raus. Ab wann hat man eigentlich ein neues Wort benutzt? Sorry, ich bin gerade so im Rant dran. Ab wann hat man gesagt, das ist doch kein Wolf mehr! Ja, dann haben wir jetzt einfach Hund, so, neues Wort, bitteschön. Das ist eine gute Frage, aber man auch zum Baum, ja, sorry. Busch gesagt, na gut, das ist was anderes. Na gut, das war ein anderes, offensichtlich etwas anderes. Baumkopf, aber wirklich, man hätte vor allem auch, ich denke mir auch so, auch der Aff, also es hätte auch jedes andere Tier sich zu einem Menschen entwickeln können, also auch Fische hätten plötzlich mega krass Werkzeuge benutzen können und so und wären super gut und wenn der Mensch da schon was aussergewögewöhnliches kommt vom Affen, der ist ja relativ random, der könnte genauso gut vom Nilpferd abstammen, dass die einfach irgendwann anfangen, aufrechtzulaufen und irgendwie Feuer zu machen und so. Aber es war genau der Affe. Es kommt ja halt, also es ist schon, glaube ich, so ein bisschen so Grösse des Gehirns und sowas, hängt auch schon zusammen. Also du brauchst halt eine gewisse... Hat der Affe das grösste Gehirn, also in Relation zum Körper? Ich glaube schon. Echt, nicht so Schnecken oder so?
Eine Relation zum Körper kann sein, aber Schnecken haben halt ein zu kleineses Gehirn, das ist irgendwann eine Form der Intelligenz. Ach so, das sind kritische Komplexität erreichten. Irgendwann im neuen Justice League Trailer fragt auch jemand Aquaman, ob er mit Fischen reden kann. Und in irgendeinem Comic hat Aquaman mal die Antwort gegeben, nein, Fische sind viel zu dämlich, mich zu verstehen, also hat er nicht so gesagt, aber Fische sind viel zu niedere Geschöpfe, als dass sie mit mir reden können. Er kommuniziert nur mit dem Organismus, dass sie irgendwen angreifen und so. Comics, wow! Ja, da bist du ja unser Comic-Experte, ne, auf jeden Fall. Das war was. Habt ihr eine tolle Olympia-Geschichte erlebt? Ja, ruft doch einfach mal an jetzt, wie die Hotline ist offen.
Jetzt, 985, 83, 83, 9.
Der Red Button schlägt gleich zu.
Wir waren bei Louis C.K., wir waren bei Bill Burr. Was ist deine Lieblingsbitte gewesen von Louis C.K.?
Ähm...
Erstmal, sorry Leute.
Ist das eigentlich Copyright, dürfen wir das jetzt eigentlich sagen?
Weiß ich nicht. Erstmal, wie geil Amsterdam. Coole Nummer. Wir sind da angekommen und die Arena, wo wir das stattfanden, waren riesen Videowürfel, es war einfach ein riesen, quasi ein riesen Videowall einfach, es waren sehr viele LEDs. Und wir kamen da an und das erste, was wir gesehen haben, war, dass mein Tweet, wo ich geschrieben habe, dass wir nach Amsterdam fahren, die ganze Arena eingenommen hat. Wie cool war das denn? Mega cool. Weil man wusste ja zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht, dass
einfach Tweets rumlaufen. Ich dachte einfach, die begrüssen mich gerade mit einem riesen Tweet. Ich dachte, die ganze Halle wäre heute in meinem Tweet beleuchtet so. Weil es kam ja zu dem Zeitpunkt an, wo der einfach schon da war. Das heißt, es war noch nicht das Bewusstsein angelangt, dass es da durchläuft. Das ist schon ziemlich cool gewesen. Das war schon ziemlich abgefahren, zumal wir ja weder jetzt irgendwie ein Hashtag oder sowas benutzt haben, der jetzt irgendwie auf dieses Ereignis hinweisen würde, sondern die es einfach gefiltert haben nach Louis C.K. plus Amsterdam plus Foto, hauen wir die alle da drauf und das war schon gut, das hat schon funktioniert. Dinge wissen sehr viel von allem, ne? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, wir haben nichts gemenschen, wir haben nichts gemenschen. Ich meine, du hast Amsterdam trotzdem noch falsch geschrieben, aber trotzdem haben sie es verstanden, das war eigentlich auch ganz, ganz gut. Ich weiss nicht, dürfen wir Bits nacherzählen? Ja. Ich meine, wir kriegen es natürlich nicht so gut hin wie Louis C.K. Aber es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen, ein bisschen ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen du brauchst einfach Kinder, glaube ich. Viele haben ja gesagt, man hört auf, lustig zu sein, wenn man keine Kinder hat. Wir hatten ja letztens diesen Tweet, wo dieses Kind gestorben ist auf der Wasserrutsche. Ja. Und dann haben wir beide Gags dazu gemacht und einer hat dann bei mir kommentiert so, ja, seit ich Kinder habe, kann ich über sowas nicht mehr lachen. Wo ich mir sofort dachte, okay, ich will nie Kinder haben. Weil wenn das ein Nebeneffekt ist, dass sich ein Teil meines Humors einfach löscht, kein Bock drauf. Ich denke mir immer, stell dich nicht so fucking an, natürlich habe ich keine Ahnung, wie es ist, Kinder zu sein, natürlich ist es noch eine ganz andere Emotionswelt, so. Aber auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, es ist ja trotzdem noch ein Gag. So, das ist so, keine Ahnung, wenn jetzt jemand einen Gag über blonde Menschen macht, kann ich ja auch als blonder Mensch drüber lachen, auch wenn es zu mir gehört, weil es ist ja trotzdem noch ein Gag, ist ja trotzdem noch eine Distanz da. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das so ein Ding ist, warum man nicht mal über tote Kinder lachen kann. Wie wahrscheinlich ist das, dass dein Kind von einer Wasserrötsche gekocht hat? Absolut, jetzt wo es schon mal passiert ist, das wird dir die längste Zeit erst mal Zeit erstmal nicht nochmal passieren. Ne, auch nicht. Also weiss ich nicht. Das finde ich immer komisch, dass man sagt, okay, nur weil das Teil meiner Persönlichkeit ist, kann ich da jetzt nicht mehr drüber lachen. Aber da sind auch nochmal Dankeschön an alle Menschen, die es da gibt, da sind ganz, ganz tolle Kommentare in diese Diskussion geflossen. Bei mir hat jemand geschrieben, ich habe dann ja gesagt, es ist ein Kind von einer Wasserrutsche im Wasserpark umgekommen und ich habe gesagt, ich würde ja sagen, es wäre jetzt an einem besseren Ort, aber es war halt in einem Wasserpark und dann hat jemand gesagt, wieso, wäre doch schön, wenn es zu Hause bei seinen Eltern gestorben wäre. Weil ich mir denke, nein, das ist genauso furchtbar, es ist auch furchtbar. Ja, willst du das, dass ein Kind bei dir zu Hause stirbt? Ich meine, es ist trotzdem, aber dass sie nicht sagt, es wäre besser, ich habe verstanden, wenn sie geschrieben hätte, diese Person, okay, nee, es ist nicht besser, es ist besser, wenn es gar nicht passiert wäre, okay, alles klar, alles klar geschenkt, das ist nicht meine Aussage gewesen, aber okay, das ist zumindest eine korrekte Aussage, aber nein, es wäre besser, wenn es mit seinen Eltern passiert wäre, da setzt du sehr viel voraus, auch was die Eltern, die Psyche der Eltern angeht und so, das ist schon seltsam. Nadima geschrieben, darunter geschrieben, nein, die meisten Unfälle passieren im Haushalt. Danke, auch nicht verstanden, aber immer noch danke. Ich glaube, es wäre ja auch noch nicht mal besser, wenn dein Kind bei dir zu Hause sterben würde, oder? Weil so kannst du sagen, okay, scheiss Sicherheitsblablub, scheiss Wasserpark, wir verklagen den Grund und Boden, die haben Schuld. Aber wenn das Kind bei dir zu Hause und vielleicht noch in deiner Nähe stirbt, machst du dir Vorwürfe für den Rest seines Lebens. Und so, okay, das Kind wollte den Wasserpark, es hatte Spaß, es war irgendwie, wir haben uns dem Vertrauen, es ist gestorben, das ist eigentlich fast einer der besten Tode, die man haben kann für ein Kind, weil du dir selber keine Vorwürfe machst. Wenn es ein Autounfall, du fährst mit dem Auto, mit dem Kind, Autounfall, Kind ist tot, du nicht, dann hast du erst mal verloren, so, für den Rest seines Lebens. Worum ging es um einen Wasserpark, Kind hatte Spaß, ist dahin gekommen, damit kann niemand rechnen, du als Elternteil kannst nicht damit rechnen, dass Kinder sterben, Wasser war es völlig harmlos. Und es hat eine gute Zeit, bevor es stirbt. Ja, absolut. Überleg mal, Wasserrutsche, yeah, yeah, yeah, tot. Aber auch schnell tot, recht schnell tot. Ja, recht schnell, es wurde geköpft, es ist ein recht schneller tot. Ist es nicht seitlich so von der Rutsche runtergefallen, dann irgendwie aufgeschlagen, gestorben und dann in die Fritteuse der Pommesbude gefallen hat? Nein, das Genick wurde genau von dem Rand der Rutsche getrennt und dann in die Fritteuse getrennt. Von dem Pfannenrand direkt. Das ist echt, die hieß Verrückt. Es war ein deutscher Name, Verrückt. Ganz seltsam. Wenn sie eins können, dann töten. Wir reden auch nur noch wie ein Mensch. Wir sind eigentlich zu dritt, wir reden einfach nur so komplett hintereinander. Wir haben neulich ein cooles Gedankenexperiment gehabt, fand ich. Wenn du jeden einen Menschen töten könntest, nee, angenommen, du kannst einen Menschen töten und einen Menschen wieder zum Leben erwecken, du könntest mich jetzt töten und dafür einen Menschen wieder zum Leben erwecken, Wäre ich die Person? Oder würdest du dir das aufheben und warten,
bis jemand, den du wirklich gerne hast, bis du den wieder erleben kannst?
Nein, natürlich. Also, auf der einen Seite...
Das ist ein mega schwieriges Richtiges.
Eigentlich nicht, weil du würdest halt irgendeinen Spacko töten
und halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hitler nochmal zurückholen und sagen,
okay, ihr Freunde, jetzt N24, lass die Kameras mal fucking laufen.
Wir machen ein Interview with that guy.
Screen time for Hitler auf N24.
Okay, kriegst du es doch noch unter.
Auf jeden Fall.
Dann tweet ihr die, die ich gestern Abend geschickt habe, auf die ich bis heute keine Antwort bekommen habe.
Nee, ich würde halt einfach irgendeinen Spacko töten, der sowieso schon im Sterben liegt.
Ja, so einfach ist das nicht. Das ist genau wie sich zwei weitere Wünsche zu wünschen. Hä, warum? Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite würde ich dich halt töten und dann zurückholen und fragen, ja wie war's? Und dann sagst du ja ist nix und dann sag ich ja, geil, danke. Ja, aber da bist du um eine … Ja, aber da kannst du jeden anderen Toten auch zurückholen. Heldenreise weiter. Kannst du jeden anderen Toten auch zurückholen, der weiss auch, wie es ist zu sterben, der erinnert sich vielleicht nicht mehr daran, aber auf der anderen Seite weiss ich nicht. Ja, man muss die Regeln noch mal ein bisschen klarer machen, glaube ich. Wenn du mich töten könntest und dafür egal wen wiederbeleben könntest, würdest du, glaube ich, mich nehmen. Ich denke mir auch so, wenn man jetzt Shakespeare zurückholen würde und Shakespeare ist wieder da, so keine Ahnung, 30 Jahre alt oder so, gut gibt es natürlich sprachlich ein bisschen Probleme, aber an sich passt das schon. So, und dann sagst du, ja gut, du hast jetzt Zeit, schreib doch noch mal ein Stück. Ob man da immer noch Bock drauf hätte, das zu sehen oder schreib mal einen Film oder schreib mal eine HBO-Serie. Guck erst mal hier American Beauty, guck erst mal Transformers 4, guck erst mal die wichtigen Filme, die der letzten Jahre entschieden sind, einfach ein bisschen up to date, was unsere Kultur angeht und dann mach mal was Neues, Wie das aussähe. Und wäre er in der heutigen Zeit noch ähnlich bekannt oder hat er nur in diesem System funktioniert damals? Ja, das ist die Frage, ob halt nicht sowas auch irgendwann abgeschlossen ist. Sie denken auch heute, also gibt es auch heute auch noch Komponisten, die klassische, klassische Musik komponieren, also so wie Schubert und Strauss oder so halt klassisch. Oder macht man heute halt, ja gut, aber Aber das ist ja auch eher so Filmmik-Scheisse und so halt so gestöhnt. Das ist ja keine Sinfonie oder so. Es sollte noch Bilder, die Bilder malen, ja, aber es sind halt andere Bilder als damals. Ja eben, du malst eben nicht mehr so, wie man vor vor Jahren gemalt hat. Du malst nicht mehr ein Rheinbrand, ein Dürer-Porträt. Du malst nicht mehr, würde ich behaupten, ein Dürer-Selbst-Porträt. Überhaupt nicht, weil ich denke mir, manchmal höre ich Melodien, ja, da da da da, und ich denke mir fuck, warum bin ich da nicht drauf gekommen. Auf der einen Seite denke ich mir, wenn ich das da da da da und denke mir, das hat ähnlich Potential. Könnte ich das noch irgendwie in modernen Popsong einbauen und wäre das trotzdem noch gut? Sind die Ideen immer noch gut oder brauchen die einfach die Ideen? Ich glaube, meine These ist ja auch, dass heutzutage jemand wie George Lucas oder so nicht mehr Star Wars drehen könnte. Es würde vielleicht, es wäre vielleicht, er würde vielleicht eine coole... Aber hätte er Star Wars dann nicht gedreht und es gäbe auch die ganze... Angenommen, es gibt Star Wars nicht. Okay, dann gibt es auch keinen Star Wars. Und er würde heutzutage Star Wars drehen, würde er es nicht dürfen, weil heutzutage sind originelle Ideen mega schwierig. Und Carrie Fisher ist zu alt. Und fucking Carrie Fisher ist zu alt und zu schlecht. Aber er würde es nicht mehr machen. Er würde vielleicht einen guten Batman mit der Story drehen dürfen. Er würde vielleicht, vielleicht wäre er sogar ein guter Regisseur, ein guter Visionär und könnte vielleicht einen guten Spider-Man oder einen guten Green Lantern oder so drehen. Aber das war's. Er würde Star Wars nicht drehen dürfen, weil Leute Angst hätten, das kommt nicht an, weil niemand weiss, ob die Geschichte ankommt. Es werden nur noch Filme gedreht, finde, dann bleibst du in einem allgemeinen popkulturellen Gedächtnis und alles ist gut. Früher war das ja nicht so. Da war keiner und Beethoven hat dann ein Konzert gegeben für 15 Adlige und die Adligen hatten halt genau, ja, mach mal noch mal ein bisschen von diesen Sonaten so. Die Sonnenscheinsonate war ganz geil, aber vielleicht fällt dir noch was anderes ein, guck mal. Und die Adligen sind heutzutage die, die Geld haben, die Filmbosser, Warner Bros. Nene, aber die Adligen haben die Musik gemacht, die sie gut fanden, die Produzenten von Warner Brothers versuchen die Filme zu machen, die die Masse gut finden. Von denen sie glauben, dass sie die Masse gut finden. Ja, aber es geht trotzdem um die Masse. Und die Frage ist, ob du nicht vielleicht zeitlose Werke wie damals Beethoven und Strauss, ja gut Beethoven und Mozart, damals nicht nur deswegen machen konntest, weil einige wenige Leute nach ihrem eigenen Geschmack, die gefördert haben und gesagt haben, das ist abgefahrener Scheiss, aber wir finden das geil und die Masse war vollkommen egal, ist nicht das vielleicht die Voraussetzung dafür, zeitlose Kunst zu erschaffen?
Also du willst eine Diktatur in der Kunst haben?
Ich will eine Kunst der Diktatur. Eine Diktatur der Kunst.
Das war schon ganz gut, was du gesagt hast. Sorry.
Ja, das willst du ja wirklich dann. Also du sagst ja, dass man Leute penetrieren muss mit Scheiss oder guten Zeug, ist völlig egal erstmal, aber dass sie sich ja irgendwann schon dran gewöhnen werden und es fressen werden. Das heisst, du willst Leute mit deinem seltsamen weirden Grenzgängerhumor, wie du immer selber von dir redest. Aber ich meine, gibt's das denn heute noch? Früher war das so, also ich habe, keine Ahnung, Beethoven und so, der wurde dann irgendwie von Leuten angestellt. Du redest so, als ob die halt dabei warst. Früher war das noch so. Ja, aber nein. Mein Gott, ich vermisse ihn doch auch. Oh Gott, oh Gott. Aber da gab es dann halt so ein paar Adlige, die ihn halt einfach gefördert haben und einfach Geld gegeben haben. So, ja, mach deinen Scheiss, hier hast du Geld. Das gibt es auch heute nicht mehr. Jemand geht zu Bono und sagt, okay, ich bin Ölscheich, ich zahle dir jeden Monat 500 Millionen Euro, mach einfach, was du willst, mach geilen Scheiss. Und die müssen sich heute auch alle durch Plattenverkäufe finanzieren. Und dieses Gönnertum, dieses Unterstützertum zu sagen, okay, du hast jemanden, der dich geil findet, der gibt... Weil ich meine, damals gab es halt auch krasse fucking Adlige, die einfach alles haben. Man erwartet aber auch heutzutage von den Künstlern, dass sie unabhängig sind. Ich meine, bei Fussballfeiern ist es ja anders, die lassen sich manchmal auch von Scheichs finanzieren und so und wollen einfach geilen Fussballspielen.
Wenn man das mal als Kunst, als Unterhaltungsobjekt sieht, ist das ja erst mal genau das Gleiche. Wenn man aber sagt, hier, dieser Hans Zimmer lässt sich von O2 finanzieren, sagt, ich geh ganz viel Geld und mach da mal keinen Scheiss draus.
Ja gut, aber O2 ist ja kein Eisner Mensch, O2 ist ja eine Firma.
Wenn jetzt nur ein einziger Typ, der viel Geld hat irgendwie, der den unterstützt und sagt,
ich finde es geil, was du machst, ich gebe dir ganz viel Geld, mach was du willst, mach genau das weiter, mach deinen komischen Nohengreen und Parsifal. Wenn jemand von euch sehr, sehr viel Geld hat, ruft uns an. Patreon.com ist die Seite eurer Wahl und schaut da mal vorbei. Aber es kann doch echt sein, vielleicht, vielleicht gibt es irgendeinen Scheich da draußen, den wir genau treffen, wo wirklich sagen, die treffen hundert Prozent das, was ich will. Ich verstehe kein Wort Deutsch, aber das Intro ist so geil. Und der schickt uns einfach Geld und sagt einfach, macht einfach weiter, ich schicke euch eine Million im Monat, macht das, kann ja sein. Aber was würden wir dann ändern an unserem Lebensstil? Gar nichts. Nichts. Du sätst halt hier nicht mehr mit Babykarotten, sondern mit echten Karotten. Echten Karotten und einem Pelz dabei, obwohl es viel zu warm ist. Wir sitzen gerade in einem Raum, der komplett abgedunkelt ist, ich sehe dich auch kaum, aber ich wäre es im Pelz hier, glaube ich. Oh, das ist hell da draußen so. Es ist so hell. Da haben wir ein bisschen Licht hier rein. Scheiss-Helligkeit, ey. Aber es riecht auch nach Schweiss einfach hier drin. Das ist furchtbar. So als ob ich Sport machen würde gerade. Diese Hitze, Mann. Ich weiss nicht mehr, wie es dir jetzt anfühlt. Ganz schrecklich. Ja. Ich weiss nicht. Wenn ihr Scheich seid und uns Geld geben wollt, haut das einfach mal raus. Dieses Gönnertum muss zurückkommen, dass man einfach sagt, warum nicht auch, man hat ja selber auch Geld, dass man einfach sagt, okay, ich finde den Künstler cool, ich unterstütze ihn einfach mal. Ja, der meint mich auch. Ich glaube, damals hatten so Adelige oder so, die hatten einfach so fucking viel Geld und auch keine Zukunftsangst, weil, okay, Adel gibt es halt einfach seit, ma, tausend Jahren, gibt es wahrscheinlich noch eine Zeit lang und bis dahin haben wir einfach überhaupt keinen Geldstress und wir können Geld einfach raushauen und jeder, selbst reiche Menschen denken sich heute wahrscheinlich, na gut, Finanzkrise ist um die Ecke, ja, Dritter Weltkrieg, Ölkram, Mars wird populiert.
Das sagen die auch, das steht auch in den Papers drin, so in den Broschüren, die sie lesen, Ölkram, Leute, Achtung, Watch out for the Ölkram, it's very serious.
Und auch da ist es schwierig, die hatten ja auch, ich meine tatsächlich, wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung, Mars, Haus auf dem Mars kostet eine Milliarde Dollar. Das könnte ja sein. Und darauf willst du ja auch sparen als reicher Mensch. Wohingegen im Mittelalter, da gab es sowas nicht. Wo man kurz mal auch darauf eingehen muss. Wir sind ja auch ein informativer Podcast und das, wo wir auf Spotify sind. Die Mitternachtsformel. Da müssen wir mal ein paar coole Sachen sagen. Die Mitternachtsformel lautet. Und zwar wurde im nächsten Sonnensystem Alpha Centauri der Planet Proximal Centauri gefunden. Mega grossartig. Also der ist in der habitablen Zone, der ist aus Gestein, die Sonne hat die richtigen Metalle rausgehauen schon, die richtigen Elemente dem Sonnensystem mit auf den Weg gegeben. Das ist so ein Glücksfall, das ist so mega gut. Können wir das mal ein bisschen mehr würdigen, als mit diesen dämlichen seltsamen Scheissartikeln, wo drunter die besten Arten beim Sex zu sterben verlinkt werden, entscheiden? Warum findet man den erst jetzt? Wie kann es sein, dass man so einen fucking Planeten, dass man so einen Planeten, ich meine so ein Planet, das ist so mit das Grösste, was es gibt. Du, es kann sogar sein, nein, absolut, es kann sogar sein, dass unser Sonnensystem noch einen sehr grossen Planeten irgendwo hat, den man aber einfach nicht sieht. Wie soll man ihn sehen? Er hat halt kein Licht. Licht ist wichtig. Aber das ist eine Sonne in der Nähe, hast du gesagt. Ja. Die reflektiert ja von den Planeten. Das ist scheißegal, das siehst du nicht mehr. Dieses Reflektionslicht, das siehst du nicht mehr. Die erkennen Planeten ja nur, doch, das weiß ich jetzt sogar. mag es, wenn Stefan in diesem Modus ist, wo auch er nicht genau weiß, auf das sind Schirmssonne nicht. Aber mach weiter, das bin ich hier auch. Weißt du, wie du Planeten entdeckst, Explaneten entdeckst du, indem du guckst, entweder schaust du auf die Sonne und misst, wie viel Licht die absondert. Und immer, wenn in dem regelmässigen Intervall das Licht, das abgegeben wird, abnimmt, weißt du, da schwebt irgendwas drumher rum. Das ist die erste Möglichkeit. Ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz, darauf eingehen. Klar. Ist die Idee dabei, dass ja auch der Planet Schwerkraft auf die Sonne ausübt und die Sonne leicht hin und her bewegt und dadurch die, die, die, die, die, die, die Distanz leicht sich verändert und damit auch die Wellenlängen anders sind? Korrekt. Oder dass der, wie so ein Schatten, dass der Planet durchs Licht fliegt. Das sind beide Möglichkeiten. Die erste Möglichkeit ist, dass der Schatten dieses Licht, was die Sonne abgibt, verringert. Und die zweite Möglichkeit ist, dass der natürlich, egal wie kleiner ist, trotzdem eine gewisse Schwerkraftbeziehung mit der Sonne eingeht und dadurch die Wellenlänge, mit der dieses Licht kommt, immer abnimmt. Kann aber sein, dass ein genau grosser Planet genau auf der anderen Seite ist und es sich immer ausgleicht. Das ist ganz, ganz spannend. Und deswegen hat man diese Möglichkeit erst seit ein paar Jahren. Und mittlerweile wurden schon hunderte Planeten entdeckt. Und das ist eine ganz, ganz tolle Zeit, in der wir wieder leben. Dreht er sich auch? Welcher? Dieser Xenozentauri? Oder nicht? Oder dreht er sich andersrum, so obenrum? Wen meinst du jetzt? Der neue Planet, der habitable Planet. Gehe ich davon aus. Ja? Ja. Aber, weiß ich jetzt nicht, keine Gewähr. Aber ich glaube, die drehen sich. Das macht Sinn. Gibt es auch Planeten, die sich nicht drehen? Ja, der Mond dreht sich halt nur einmal um sich selbst, wenn er einmal um die Erde dreht. Gebundene Rotation, ganz anderes Thema. Ist das eigentlich Zufall, dass der Mond so gebunden rotiert, oder ist es … Nein, nein, hat sich irgendwann angeglichen. War auch mal anders. Wie angeglichen? Die Rotation hat sich der Erde angeglichen. Aber warum? Die mondeigene Relation. Hat denn die Schwerkraft eine Auswirkung auf die Rotation auch? Ja, klar. Es bremst es ja irgendwann. Warum hat die Schwerkraft einen Effekt auf die Rotation? Das verstehe ich nicht. Verarsche mich gerade ein bisschen. Nee, ich meine nicht, dass der Mond sich um die Erde dreht, sondern dass der Mond rotiert. Ja, er rotiert sich ja. Er rotiert ja einmal, während er um die Erde dreht, hat er sich einmal um sich selber gedreht. Ja, aber warum kann er sich nicht... Er zeigt der Erde immer denselben Punkt. Warum kann er... Ich sehe einfach so das kollektive Geräusch von 208-Klässlern, die einfach sagen, ach Gott, ihr Vollidioten. Facepaw, Facepaw. Aber warum... Aber das verstehe ich nicht. Warum passt er sich an? Er zeigt der Erde seine Schokoladenseite. Wir benutzen ein anderes Vokabular, okay, wir gehen jetzt von einem Horizont eines vierjährigen aus. Ich wurde schon mal massiv beleidigt von unseren Hörern, weil ich das falsch erklärt habe. Also ich habe mit meinem Anwalt die Wortwahl genau durchgegangen. Der Mond zeigt der Erde immer seine Schokoladenseite, immer seine beste Seite. Das verstehe ich schon, aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich kein Zufall, dass er sich genauso schnell dreht. Aber warum, was ist der Effekt, der dazu führt? Wie gesagt, der ist sehr, sehr schwer, hat also so Einfluss auf die Erde, wie die Erde Einfluss auf ihn hat. Und deswegen, der würde halt Energie verschwenden, wenn er sich drehen würde. Warum? Der hat ja doch keinen Widerstand. Er wird halt gebremst von der Erdrotation. Ja, so genau weiß ich das auch nicht, auch nicht, ey. Okay, vielleicht ist es ganz simpel. Oh, kurz übernommen. Sagen wir mal das Astronomie-Forum. Wir können auch meinen guten Freund Philipp Hauptmann anrufen. Ja, komm, wir rufen mal Philipp Hauptmann an. Warum sollte er das wissen? Weil er Physik studiert. Ja, und? Vielleicht hat er sich aber auf andere Dinge konzentriert. Hi Pete, folgendes. Hallo, hier ist Stefan auch. Du bist gerade im Podcast UFO Podcast. Wir haben eine physikalische Frage. Hast du ganz kurz Zeit? Kommt dran, aber gerne. Also, es geht um die Erde und den Mond.. Wer dreht sich noch mal um was? Nein, also der der der Mond rotiert ja so, dass er immer der Erde dieselbe Seite zeigt. Gebundene Rotation, so entnehmen wir schon. Tidally locked heißt das Erde dran und ist sehr viel leichter als die Erde und ist deswegen tidally locked. Es ist sehr spannend, dass du das fragst, weil erst gestern wurde ein neuer Planet um Proxima Centauri gefunden, und dieser ist tidally locked. Aber warum hat denn die Schwerkraft Einfluss auf die Rotation? Aber der hat ja … Das hat damit zu tun … Also ich bin jetzt kein Experte, was das angeht, aber soweit ich weiss, hat das damit zu tun, dass das da schon sehr lange außen rumkreist und du Energie verlierst bei jeder Rotation, so wie wir auch zum Beispiel die Ebbe und die Flut haben, was auch ein Energieverlust ist und der Mond kommt ja auch immer näher, oder wie war das, auf jeden Fall das hat einen Einwirkung, aber da gibt es andere Effekte auch, egal. Aber beim Mond, da ist doch kein Luftwiderstand oder so, warum verliert der Energie, wenn er sich dreht? Ja, eben durch so Interaktionseffekte, dass zum Beispiel die Ebbe und die Flut passieren, das ist Reibung, also das erzeugt Ebbe und die Flut, die Ebbe und die Flut dreht sich um die Erde, also dieses Wasser, das sich um die Erde herumdreht, hat Reibungseffekte, logischerweise, aber das Wasser sich hier bewegt, und diese Reibungseffekte verliert ja nicht die Erdwohn dazu, also das dann wirklich auf den Mond. Energie erhalten. Ach was. Ja. Damit kann man eigentlich alles beschreiben. Ja, sicher. Deswegen ist ja Physik sehr einfach. Studiert Physik heute. Das heisst aber, also rotiert dann auch die Erde immer langsamer, weil sie dann Energie an die Sonne verliert? Ja, lange ist es halt schon. Das heisst, alle Planeten hören irgendwann auf, sich zu drehen. Und knallen in die Sonne rein. Ja, das man gar nicht so einfach nicht sagen, da gibt es auch ein paar andere Effekte, aber es hat auf jeden Fall einen Einfluss. Ich bin jetzt kein Kepler-Experte, was da genau passiert, aber es hat auf jeden Fall alles einen Einfluss. Das schon, also du fliegst nicht durch einen luftleeren Raum, außerdem ist auch die Sonne ja kein fester Körper, sondern auch ein Plasma, das macht Sachen und bewegt sich und das interagiert. Und zum Beispiel mit dieser Interaktion kam man sogar, eben haben wir zum Beispiel diesen Planeten und Proxima Centaur gefunden, und zwar die Sonne, also dieser Proxima Centaur ist ein Stern, und um den kreist dieser Planet. Und diese Erde, also diese Sonne, diese Grosse, der Stern, der reagiert auf den Planeten, zwar minimal, also der ist ungefähr, die Geschwindigkeit beschleunigt er sich in die Richtung des Planeten. Und durch diese leichte Bewegung kannst du sagen, dass es überhaupt ein Planet aus Rom gibt. Und diese Bewegung, und diese Bewegung, die wiederum ist Energie natürlich, die muss irgendwo herkommen. Stimmt, die muss irgendwo herkommen. Ach cool. Super, vielen Dank, ey. Ja cool, vielen Dank für die Antwort. Wenn da irgendwas Falsches bei mir, wirst du extrem viel Hass erfahren in den nächsten Monaten. Community wird dich haten. Aber wenn das richtig war, dann wirst du geliebt. Vielen Dank an unseren Astronomie-Experten Philipp Hauptmann. Dankeschön. Schönen Tag noch. Hau rein. Ciao. Wow, tatsächlich. Nicht schlecht, Stefan. War bei uns relativ viel falsch auch. Also ich habe ja gesagt, der Planet dreht sich, weil ich es behauptet habe. Aber anscheinend haben die den deshalb entdeckt, weil er sich nicht gedreht hat. Das ist ja auch interessant. Mit Schrittgeschwindigkeit. Habe ich jetzt nicht genannt. Ah scheisse, hört euch die Folge noch mal an, dann gehen wir noch mal Bezug darauf. Wir sollten aufhören, über sowas zu reden. Das ist über Dina-Lisa oder so sprechen, über das, was wir verstanden haben. Lass uns mal zurück zum Abschluss von Louis C.K. kommen. Wie hat sie gefallen, beste Gags, was waren noch Erlebnisse? Das war ein echt tolles, es waren die besten zwei Stunden meines Lebens, sage ich immer, auch weil ich ein bisschen übertreibe, weil ich den Leuten das Gefühl von Neid irgendwie übertragen will. Es hat echt Spaß gemacht. Mega krasser Typ, hat die Masse im Griff gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, viele tausende Leute waren da in einer mega modernen Halle, die eine eigene Währung hatte. Diese Halle hatte eine fucking eigene Währung. Also nicht nur Amsterdam, sondern diese Halle. Du kamst in diese Halle und ich wollte mir bei so einem Süssigkeitenstand so eine Tüte zusammenstellen aus verschiedenen Sachen. Und da wollte ich zahlen und er sagte, dieses Geld nehmen wir hier nicht. Und dann habe ich gesagt, was? Dann habe ich gesagt, ja hier gibt es Munden. Munden. Und dann musste man zum Automaten und die Währung umtauschen. Und nicht mal das haben wir geschafft, wir haben nicht mal diesen Automaten verstanden. Und es war eine ganz seltsame Währung, nämlich hast du einen Chip bekommen und es gab auch halbe Munden. Genau. Und ich mir dachte, warum macht ihr das, ihr könnt selber entscheiden, wie viel Wert das hat, warum gibt einem Munden nicht so viel Wert, das ist immer gerade Zeit, weil man konnte es durchreisen. Du kannst keinen Euro, kannst du auch nicht in der Mitte durchschneiden, dann hast du 50 Cent. Ja, man hat so quadratische Plastikplättchen, so ein Quadratzentimeter ungefähr und die konntest du nochmal diagonal auseinanderbringen, was echt merkwürdig ist. Das ist wirklich merkwürdig, r rückblickend echt seltsam. Ihr könnt selber den Wert bestimmen. Kann man selber den Wert von der eigenen Währung bestimmen? Ich weiss nicht. Wertenwagensystem. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall noch einen halben Munden, habe ich noch übrig gelassen, weil du, weißt du, ein Smoothie kostet vier Munden und eine Cola kostet drei Munden. Das heisst, mathematisch hast du einfach immer irgendwas übrig. Na, keine Ahnung, das ist mir egal, das stimmt. Aber auf jeden Fall hast du immer irgendwie was übrig und ich habe einen halben Munden mitgenommen. Weil die meisten sind zu faul, danach nochmal hinzugehen, die Munden nochmal in Euro umzutauschen. Und davon leben die ja auch. Davon leben die. Davon lädt Louis C. Gale vom Munden. Aber das gibt es ja oft so bei... Wurde Louis C. Gale in Munden bezahlt? Deswegen treten die meisten noch nicht da auf, weil die dachten, nee. Aber das ist ja so die Idee, das gibt es ja auch oft bei Apps, also bei Pokémon Go zum Beispiel, da kannst du ja auch mit Geld zum Beispiel Pokébälle kaufen, aber du kaufst nicht direkt mit Geld Pokébälle, sondern du kaufst dir erst Goldmünzen und mit den Goldmünzen kaufst dann die Pokébälle, damit verschleiert wird, wie viel so ein Pokéball wirklich kostet. Weil wenn da immer der Eurowert stehen würde, würdest du dir denken, na, das ist vielleicht ganz schön teuer, Aber da ist immer dieser Goldwert und du einfach keinen, da kosten dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 80 Goldmünzen kosten dann 1,20 Euro, das heisst du, na gut, 1,30 Euro, das ist schwer umzusetzen. Das heisst, du vergisst irgendwann, was diese Goldmünzen wert sind und kaufst dann einmal diese Goldmünzen. Ist das in dieser Halle der gleiche Effekt, weil Munden habe ich rausgehauen, wie es geht, also ich habe die durch die Gegend geworfen, die haben irgendwie in die Panties gesteckt, wo es nur ging, habe die einfach rausgeballert.
I need a Munden, Munden is what I need, hat er gesungen immer. Heute wird mehr gesungen.
It's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Morden, Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Morden, Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Morden, Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Morden, Munden, Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Morden, Munden, Munden, Munden, Munden, Munden, it's not about the Mock, it's not about the Mock.
Fuck, ey, ich höre diesen Song jeden Tag und kann ihn nicht. Ja, aber das fand ich echt interessant. Vor allem, es kann ja sein, dass du irgendwann mal, wenn du aus deinem Eisschlaf aufwachst, aufgeweckt wirst, und dann ist Munden die vorherrschende Währung auf Proxima Centauri und du bist dann da plötzlich. Und dann stürmen alle diese Halle um diesen Munden. Mit einem halben Munden kannst du das in den Planet einfach einnehmen. Wie gut wäre das denn? Das stimmt. Falls ihr noch Munden habt, schickt ihr uns einfach. Wir brauchen die. Und da können wir so eine Munden-Annahmestelle machen. Aber jetzt auch Patrio nur noch in Munden. Ein T-Shirt kostet ja ein bisschen nur fünf Munden. Das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Das besteht auch nur aus dem Munden. Weil ich hatte dann diese Süßigkeitentüte, konnte die nicht bezahlen, weil ich keine Munden hatte. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich kann jetzt schlicht wieder zurück tun, können Sie die kurz behalten? Und dann hat er so eine Schublade aufgemacht, wo ganz viele Tüten drin waren und hat diese reingeschmissen und wieder zugemacht. Wo ich mir denke, das ist wahrscheinlich vielen Leuten passiert, die sagen, ja okay, fuck, ich will keine von diesen Munden haben. Und er parkt einfach 50 Munden-Tüten. Ja, genau, und dann kam ich wieder zurück und er hat mir die Tüte gegeben und es war exakt dieselbe Tüte, obwohl er die einfach lieblos reingeworfen hat. Also es war echt verrückt. Und er hatte auch, Louis Scker hatte auch drei Four-Bands quasi, also drei Four-Acts. Wendell der Sky, Ice Blue und Ice Team. Mann, ich werde kein echter Bandtitel eingefallen, ey. Oh, fuck you. Es war glaube ich schwieriger, daneben zu schliessen jetzt. Wendell der Sky. Was war das zweite?blue? Und Eiscube. Aber ein von drei ist er versenkt. Nailed it. 30 Prozent. Stefan, er hat einen Munden verschluckt. Eine Babykarotte. So, und das ist eine echte Karotte. Gewesen. Dann würde ich jetzt nicht mal unter uns weinen. Willst du das wieder Stand-Up machen? Ich will nämlich das wieder Stand-Up machen. Ich bin so beeinflussbar. Ja, aber auf der einen Seite einen Seite denkt man sich, man wird nie so gut wie der, auf jeden Fall, wenn du irgendwann so viele Munden hast, denkst du ja geil. Aber es war ja nicht so, also ich bin extrem selten auf Konzerten, also noch nie, ich war auf einem Oli-Schulz-Konzern sonst nie, aber solche Hallen werden ja, also was ich sagen will, ist, wir sassen da in diesen Rängen und wir mussten... Was ich sagen will, Schmetterlinge sind ziemlich unterbreitet. Wir mussten die ganze Zeit nach links gucken, weil links Louis war auf der Bühne und da gab es auch zwei große Monitore. Und erstens mal habe ich immer auf die Monitore geschaut, weil er näher zu sehen war. Da dachte ich mir, nee, eigentlich, du darfst nicht auf die Monitore schauen, du musst auf das kleine Mädchen gucken, weil du bist extra hier, du hast extra vierundsechzig Munden ausgegeben, um hier sein zu dürfen. Also schau den Mann auch an, auch wenn du nichts siehst, auch wenn du nicht siehst, ob das nicht vielleicht irgendwie der Feuerbrandschutzbeauftragte ist, der daneben steht. Vielleicht guckst du den die ganze Zeit an. Aber ich konnte nicht auf den Monitor gucken. Es waren zwei grosse Monitore zu sehen, wo er in High Definition 4K, 3D, 360 Grad zu sehen war. Und man hat da drauf geguckt, natürlich. Ich habe irgendwann gesagt, okay, ich war irgendwann zu faul, auf diesen kleinen Menschen zu gucken, habe dann auf den Monitor geguckt und habe gesagt, okay, du hörst aber dafür das Lachen live, du hörst ihn gerade live, das ist alles schon, das muss reichen. Und vor allem, also ich hab momentan echt ein massives Problem mit Aufmerksamkeit, dass ich nach Hause komme und denke, geil, neue Folge Newsroom, neue Folge Marin, schau ich alles an, geil, und dann fange ich an. Und die alten Folgen findet ihr auf unserer Website bei iTunes.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wenn wir Florian-Thien war, sich einen Nachmittag dahin setzen.
Alles klar, alles Gute von mir, Stefan Tietze, alles Gute von dir.
Viel Spaß mit der Website und Technik, haut rein, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao! Und wir heben ab!